prime minister is the end date for the
operation in afghanistan western forces
still august the 31st have you secured
any more time for the evacuation efforts
in kabul i think sam first of all you've
got to understand
quite how much has been achieved already
just since the the 14th of august this
is an extraordinary airlifter we've
evacuated
9 000 the uk alone has taken uh 9 000
people out of out of kabul i think 57
flights a huge huge effort by our
military and we will go on right up
until the the last moment that we that
we can but you you've heard what the
president united states has had so
you've heard what the uh the taliban
have said and i think you've got to
understand the context in which we're
we're doing this we're confident we can
get thousands more out but the situation
at the airport is is not getting any
better there's a there are public order
issues it's uh it's uh there are
harrowing scenes for those who are who
are trying to get out
and uh it's tough for our military as
well and so what we've we've done today
the g7
is we've we've got together the the
leading western powers and agreed uh not
just a
uh
joint approach to dealing with the the
evacuation but also a road map for the
way in which we're going to engage uh
with the taliban as it probably will be
a taliban
government in uh in
in kabul and
the number one condition
we're setting
as g7
is that they've got to guarantee
right the way through uh through august
the 31st and beyond a safe passage safe
passage for those who who want to to
come out now someone will say uh that
they don't accept that and some of them
i hope i will see the sense of that
because the g7
has very considerable leverage uh
economic diplomatic and uh and political
so
you failed did you or any other g7
leader make clear your frustration to
president biden about how the events
there unfolded
up to last week and his refusal to
extend the august 31st deadline which is
something that you wanted
let's be clear the the the immediate
phase of the evacuation is actually
being a a very considerable
uh
success by the military and i think most
people looking at the numbers that uh we
have got out would say it was quite
remarkable that since the 14th of august
we've got uh 9 000 people uh coming to
to this country are hoping to make new
lives and obviously we're having to to
check them to vet them uh there are all
sorts of processes uh that we have to go
through but nine thousand is a very
considerable number that's that's uk
nationals uh plus who who have been in
afghanistan but it's also
those who have helped us during the last
two decades and it's the uk showing its
commitment showing its responsibility uh
to those people and i think we can be
very proud of what we're achieving so
you present a pretty rosy world in which
the west can engage with taliban 2.0
what earth leverage does the west as the
g7 does britain have over a taliban-led
government what makes you think that
they're going to want to engage and
listen to our demands for things like
safe passage out of afghanistan i i
totally realistic about the
the taliban and i don't think that
anybody is going to pretend that this is
anything other than you know a very
difficult
situation but that doesn't mean
that we should ignore the leverage that
we have we want to help with the
humanitarian uh
crisis the difficulties that people in
afghanistan people fleeing afghanistan
are going to experience but when it
comes to uh engaging with the with the
taliban and engaging with the government
uh in
afghanistan whatever it's its exact
composition the g7 has huge leverage and
today uh the g7 agreed uh we brought
them together and they agreed a road map
for future engagement uh with the
taliban so that you know if those huge
funds are going to be unfrozen
eventually uh for uh use by the the
government and people of of afghanistan
then uh what we're saying is afghanistan
can't lurch back into becoming a
breeding ground of terror afghanistan
can't become a a narco state
girls have got to be educated up to the
age of 18
and and so on and those are important
things that we value as g7 uh those are
things that unite us in the ways
those are things by the way for which uh
we
we fought for
years in afghanistan and uh for which
people in this country uh gave their
lives and
the point that was made today by g7
leaders is that we remain
committed to those values and we remain
committed to afghanistan but the number
one condition
that we're
insisting upon is safe passage
beyond the 31st so beyond this initial
phase for those who want to leave
afghanistan finally prime minister in
the event
that al canoida
and is expand in afghanistan
is there any possibility that g7 troops
return to that country
i i think you've got to recognize that
the
the history of afghanistan is
uh is cyclical sadly and
you'll have seen
over different epochs different
expeditionary forces sent in by
different powers with the view to trying
to stabilize the country our our own
country has had uh centuries of
experience in in afghanistan
but what i hope
is that there is now a different path
forward and a better future and
uh you know i i don't think anybody is
going to uh believe that this is going
to be easy or that this is uh likely in
the short term but there's there's got
to be a a world in which the people of
afghanistan and the the the
find the leadership find the wisdom to
come together to to make accommodations
with each other for the for the pashtun
to
to sit down with the tajiks and the
uzbeks and the and the turkmens and the
whole all the factions to get together
finally uh to agree on a way forward for
that country and i think possibly what
uh the point that joe biden has been
trying to make
is it is very difficult for western
powers to try to impose uh that sort of
order on a country if a country is
unwilling to do it itself and i think
what we all want to see now is
the un uh helping to lead a political
process that will try to bring
afghanistan forward take it to a to a
different future without uh afghanistan
feeling it has to to subcontract or
outsource its government uh to uh to
foreign powers or to expeditionary
forces that's got to be what we're all
working for it'll take patience and it
will take time
but in the meantime what we need to do
is to use our very very considerable
influence as g7
to work on uh the the new powers in
afghanistan to insist on safe passage
and
to follow the the path that we think is
compatible with our values and which
will enable us to engage positively with
them in the future